[Musique]
le sommeil est devenu aujourd'hui un
véritable enjeu de santé publique
un Français sur 3 souffre de troubles du
sommeil et la population militaire ne
fait pas exception en opération ils sont
confrontés à des activités quasi
ininterrompues ne leur offrant que de
rares périodes de repos
face à cette problématique des médecins
cherchent en militaires étudie les
mécanismes du sommeil leur mission aider
les combattants à mieux gérer leur
fatigue pour rester vigilants quelles
sont les conséquences d'une privation de
sommeil et quelles peuvent être les
méthodes pour lutter contre la fatigue
une équipe du journal de la défense est
allé à la rencontre des médecins et des
chercheurs du service de santé désormais
mais aussi de militaires sur le terrain
pour connaître les bons outils de
gestion de la fatigue opérationnelle
vous relâchez les temps vous êtes bien
[Musique]
là dans les véhicules dès qu'on a un
temps mort ou le matin on s'est levé
très tôt et qu'on a une heure de roulage
les mecs ils dorment pendant une
demi-heure il y en a un qui est toujours
en permanence à l'arrière et puis après
on a le terme chacun se repose un petit
peu dès qu'on a un temps mort
ces dernières années avec l'augmentation
du rythme des missions la gestion du
sommeil la fatigue et la récupération
sont devenus des problématiques
importantes chez les militaires pour y
répondre l'unité fatigue et vigilance de
l'Institut de recherche biomédicale des
armées étudie les causes et les effets
du manque de sommeil et met au point des
stratégies pour y remédier
le sommeil c'est une mise au repos de
l'organisme qui permet tout d'abord de
se régénérer sur le plan énergétique de
reconstituer les réserves en énergie
sans sommeil la première fonction qui
est altérée c'est l'éveil sont d'abord
somnolents on a une diminution de notre
capacité d'attention les pieds également
on va avoir une télécrattation des
processus cognitifs plus complexes la
prise de décision également l'humeur les
capacités de réflexion
je teste va nous permettre de savoir si
après ta privation de sommeil ta
réactivité au froid et modifier ou pas
avec son équipe le médecin chef Fabien
teste la résistance de 4 sujets à la
fatigue
pendant plus de 40 heures c'est 4
militaires doivent rester éveillés et
réaliser des tests cognitifs et des
séries d'exercices ce qui caractérise
les activités militaires c'est qu'elles
ont lieu à n'importe quelle heure du
jour et de la nuit qu'elles peuvent être
également sur des durées étendues
pendant 20 30 40 heures et cela perturbe
le rytv sommeil induit une dette de
sommeil qui peut être une dette de
sommeil aiguë je fais une nuit blanche
ou alors une dette de sommeil chronique
c'est-à-dire je vais dormir 5 à 6 heures
par nuit et ce pendant plusieurs mois
la dégradation des performances
cognitives et psychomotrices débutent
dès la 26e heure de privation de sommeil
ce qui n'est pas sans conséquence alors
détends-toi bien
est-ce que tu peux fermer les yeux
Mégane s'il te plaît selon les dettes
chroniques de sommeil favorisent
l'apparition de pathologies on a plus
facilement des infections ORL pulmonaire
on peut également avoir des blessures
qui sont favorisées par la dette de
sommeil et puis à long terme ou
plusieurs années la dette de sommeil
favorise l'apparition de pathologies
cardiovasculaires infarctus du myocarde
le diabète et même également
l'apparition de certains cancers
tu pars dans 3 2 1 c'est parti allez
verrouille
les principales contre les mesures qui
permettent d'améliorer sa tolérance à la
privation de sommeil c'est tout d'abord
d'avoir un sommeil de qualité dans des
bonnes conditions l'obscurité le calme
avec une durée suffisante et
principalement à sommet qui est pris de
nuit
on a démontré par des études de
laboratoire que si on pratique une
activité physique régulière ce qui est
caché un grand nombre de nos militaires
on est plus résistant à la privation
sommeil on récupère beaucoup plus vite à
l'issue de celle-ci ensuite il y a des
contre-mesures qui sont utilisées au
cours de la dette de sommeil comme la
sieste l'exposition à la lumière
l'utilisation de la caféine qui permet
de limiter la dégradation des
performances
dans le cas d'opération spécifique un
médicament éveillant peut être prescrit
son utilisation est régie par un texte
de loi très stricte
on ne peut utiliser pour maintenir un
minitaire éveillé qu'une caféine à
libération prolongée qui est mis dans un
médicament qui sous forme d'éponge et
qui va du coup se libérer pendant 6 à 8
heures c'est le seul médicament qu'on
utilise d'autres pays utilisent d'autres
médicaments par exemple utilisant
fetamine pour maintenir leur personnel
éveillé nous ne souhaitons pas liser ces
médicaments ce qu'on veut c'est un
militaire qui est certes éveillé mais
avec toutes ses capacités mentales
par contre les médecins des forces
peuvent utiliser dans le cas de cette
instruction des médicaments qui peuvent
favoriser le sommeil dans certaines
situations volumine une terre en
opération qui fait une mission de nuit
qui doit dormir de jour mais cela est
très encadré et soumis à une
prescription médicale
veillez durant de longues heures tout en
restant vigilant voilà le défi que
doivent relever au quotidien nos
militaires récemment des pilotes rafales
ont réalisé un vol record de plus de 12
heures aux limites des capacités
physiques de l'équipage
direction la base aérienne de
Saint-Dizier à la rencontre d'un de ses
pilotes en opération la mission elle
peut durer de 4 à 7 heures après on peut
aller jusqu'à le maximum en ce moment
c'est 12h c'est vraiment pour des
missions stratégiques
les périodes danses dans ces périodes
d'ancien problème parce que le stress et
la concentration augmente un peu le
rythme cardiaque du coup il y a pas de
problème d'endormissement et pendant les
phases un peu plus tranquille et ben
soit on discute
entre équipage soit on essaie de prendre
part à la radio à d'autres missions qui
sont pas trop loin
pourquoi en voiture au bout d'une heure
on est capable de s'endormir au volant
alors que dans un avion non en fait sans
le savoir on est continuellement en
activité le cerveau est tout le temps en
train de rechercher des informations des
calculs de carburant des changements de
fréquence radio on a toujours une
activité qu'on n'aurait pas en voiture
dans les airs les performances physiques
et physiologiques peuvent être altérées
pour garantir la sécurité des vols les
médecins aéronautiques sensibilisent
régulièrement les personnels navigants
aux effets de la fatigue c'est un pilote
qu'on a vu ce matin
ça c'est le CG antérieur l'année
dernière la fatigue dans l'aéronautique
c'est une problématique qui est
constante qui est expliqué par de très
nombreux facteurs ils tiennent plus
spécifiquement à ce qu'on appelle les
contraintes aéronautiques d'hypoxie avec
une discrète hippopary dont les
variations thermiques l'air sec dans les
cabines pressurisées le confinement les
accélérations dans les aéronefs de
chasse sont des éléments qui peuvent
être source de fatigue
le pilote il est suivi périodiquement
tous les six mois et le médecin peut
détecter éventuellement des pathologies
qui pourraient être source
d'hypovigilance de somnolence à
l'intérieur des aéronefs le médecin va
aussi l'aider avec le Service des Sports
à sa préparation physique il faut qu'il
ait une excellente hygiène de vie il
faut que le sommeil soit d'excellentes
qualités et il peut se servir à des
techniques d'optimisation du potentiel
des missions extrêmes à la fois dans les
airs mais aussi sous l'eau à bord des
sous-marins la mauvaise qualité du
sommeil n'est pas une légende
grâce à notamment deux hormones la
mélatonine pour s'endormir le cortisol
pour se réveiller et donc cette horloge
biologique qui repose notamment mais pas
que mais sur ces deux hormones
on a besoin de lumière naturelle pour
organiser ce rythme hormonal et sans
cette lumière naturelle aborde un
sous-marin on l'a plus on perd un petit
peu l'effet horloge biologique et donc
on a un sommeil qui est de moins bonne
qualité désorganisé et donc on est plus
fatigué
de pas voir la lumière naturelle pendant
60 90 jours d'affilée sur sous-marin on
a montré que ça pouvait s'apparenter à
un petit peu à de l'hiver polaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on a c'est pas tout à
fait pareil un petit syndrome de
dépression saisonnière qui s'installe
parce que les sous-mariniers
intuitivement on va plus le syndrome de
j40 tu as aucun centième jour on se sent
plus ralenti moins performants
la vie en mer est rythmée par les cars
ce sont les tranches horaires pendant
lesquels les marins travaillent soit
leur spécialité soit l'entretien du
navire ou sont au repos et cela deux
jours comme de nuit
dans les sous-marins ce rythme régulier
est plus dense en raison d'un personnel
restreint à bord on parle alors de
Tiercé c'est trois opérateurs pour
couvrir ces cartes et ben chez quelqu'un
qui tourne entière sec au bout de 60
jours c'est comme s'il avait fait 10
nuits blanches donc ça on voit très bien
que au bout de quelques jours le on est
extrêmement fatigué et donc la crainte
c'est l'hypovigilance l'erreur humaine
enfin et tout ça c'est multiplié de
façon exponentielle par la fatigue
induite par la prévention de sommeil de
ces rythmes de cas
alors vous avez accumulé de la fatigue
donc faut pas se stresser c'est normal
vous allez partir en entière sec pendant
votre mission là il faut essayer de
faire des siestes dès que vous pouvez
après si vous avez l'opportunité de
dormir plus et c'est de se coucher
d'avoir une technique pour s'endormir il
faut pas d'écran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe est fatigué chacun chacun
individu est fatigué par son rythme de
car et ben on peut espérer que des
erreurs qui sont faites par l'individu
soit rattraper par le reste du groupe
après c'est on enfonce une porte ouverte
mais il faut dormir tout tout ce qu'on
peut il faut essayer de récupérer ces
fameux cycles de sommeil qu'on a perdu
faire des siestes et dans le 1 0 les
gars
[Musique]
un manque de sommeil aggravé par une
utilisation accrue d'écran qui peut
avoir des effets pervers
avant dans un sous-marin il y a les gens
avaient pas leur ordinateur personnel ou
leur tablettes ou leur écran un des gros
travers qui est pris par le
sous-mariniers actuellement c'est que la
personne sort de car va se coucher il
ouvre son écran il regarde un film et ça
nous les médecins aujourd'hui ça faut
pas faire ça diminue le lien social à
bord mais en plus c'est un impact direct
sur la qualité de l'endormissement
concilier sommeil et performances
opérationnelle est un vrai enjeu pour
les armées l'Académie des forces
spéciales de l'armée de terre prend très
au sérieux cette problématique elle a
d'ailleurs mis en place des actions pour
sensibiliser ses hommes
pour une mission de force spéciale c'est
longue période d'attente mais en
revanche des mobilisations très rapides
sur une intervention nous nous sommes
des sportifs de haut niveau très
particulier que l'on doit sur une
période de 2 à 4 mois en fonction des
spécialités être capable de mobiliser
ses capacités à la au claquement de
doigts c'est pas planifié sur les quatre
et pour préparer au mieux leurs missions
l'Académie encourage ces hommes à
pratiquer des techniques d'optimisation
du potentiel prenez conscience
de chaque inspiration
et de chaque expiration
[Musique]
ici et maintenant vous pouvez vous
étirer vous frottez le visage
nous avons réalisé depuis plusieurs
années que nous avions beaucoup de
pertes psychologiques et un des facteurs
communs des pertes psychologiques c'est
la fatigue puis vous allez augmenter la
partie technologique puis il faut
augmenter l'entraînement de commando et
notamment sa préparation mentale donc le
soldat augmenté pour les Forces
Spéciales c'est quelqu'un qui gère son
sommeil et qui sait séquencer son
sommeil en petit tronçon par des
systèmes de micro-siestes ou de siestes
rapides qui vont permettre à l'opérateur
durant la mission mais dans les phases
de relâche de pouvoir se reposer dans
ces moments clés
c'est tout en naturel c'est tout en
préparation mentale c'est la remise en
confiance des individus c'est leur
apprendre que effectivement il y a des
moments qui vous ça va faire mal des
moments qui vont être douloureux et
quand l'anticipe le cerveau l'intègre un
peu mieux et le gère de façon plus
positive
on est vraiment dans l'individualisation
de la gestion de la fatigue et derrière
le garçon quand on lui dira bon écoute
on estime que tu es fatigué tel niveau
on te conseille de faire tel type de
récupération de la micro siège assez
sous hypnose ou un autre mode de
récupération
pour favoriser cette récupération la
structure s'est même dotée d'un fauteuil
sensoriel
[Musique]
ces sensations je vais t'enlever ce
casque j'aimerais avoir tes petites
impressions par rapport à
depuis 2017 l'Académie a mis en place un
séminaire sur l'augmentation du
potentiel et la gestion de la fatigue
opérationnelle
objectif accroître les performances des
forces spéciales tout en faisant de la
prévention sur les risques
psychologiques combien de fois vous avez
pris la voiture pour les gens qui
conduisent et vous êtes arrivés à la
maison et vous vous rappelez pas des
cinq derniers kilomètres puis vous êtes
fatigué moins vous gérez effectivement
la partie frustration gestion du stress
et mobilisation intellectuelle donc plus
on va permettre aux gens d'être reposé
puis ils auront le sentiment de savoir
gérer leur frustration meilleur
risqueront dans la conception puis
derrière la réalisation des opérations
le manque de sommeil et la fatigue
opérationnelle son objet d'une vigilance
particulière par les spécialistes de la
santé mentale du service de santé des
armées
psychiatre et psychologue militaire
distinguent d'une part les effets du
stress lié au contrats opérationnelles
et d'autres parts ceux qui sont générés
par un traumatisme psychique pouvant
évoluer vers un état de stress
post-traumatique on sait que la fatigue
opérationnelle peut être un facteur de
risque dans un climat de d'engagement
très dense et il n'y a pas de causalité
linéaire entre un facteur de risque et
l'émergence de l'état de stress
post-traumatique mais la question de la
fatigue doit naturellement être prise
très au sérieux pour que le combattant
puisse mobiliser ses ressources à tout
moment et en particulier dans cet
instant de la rencontre traumatique s'il
y a rencontre romantique l'état de
stress post-traumatique résulte de la
perturbation de l'équilibre psychique en
relation avec un événement dit
traumatique une rencontre soudaine
fulgurante et imprévisible avec la mort
la sienne ou celle d'autrui les
caractéristiques de cette réaction
psychique sont marquées par trois
grandes catégories de symptômes les
reviviscences à l'état de veille la nuit
les fameux cauchemars réplicatifs la
scène de se revient à l'identique on
l'appelle le cauchemartre mytique on a
également des symptômes de la lignée de
plutôt de l'hyper vigilance de
l'hyper-réveil qui peut avoir des
incidences aussi sur le sommeil et puis
enfin les symptômes marqués par
l'évitement le repli-social
l'agoraphobie quelqu'un qui est épuisé
elle aura pas tendance à aller vers les
soins à aller vers le camarade donc il
faut vraiment considérer la fatigue
opérationnelle comme un facteur de
risque psychique qui doit être pris en
compte par le service de santé des
armées mais aussi par le commandement
dans l'organisation du cycle de la vie
opérationnelle
[Musique]
les imbrications entre le sommeil et
l'état de stress post-traumatique sont à
la fois sous-estimés et très complexes
il y a probablement un phénomène de
cercle vicieux finalement l'état de
stress post-traumatique la pathologie
génère un sommeil de mosquée
l'insomniechronique vient contribuer à
ce que la pathologie se chronicise que
les phénomènes s'entretiennent comme ça
et donc vous comprenez bien que état de
stress post traumatique troubles du
sommeil chronique insomnie chronique
état de stress post-traumatique et ça se
répond comme ça et c'est en ça qu'il y a
un vrai intérêt à pouvoir dépister le
plus précocément possible cette
pathologie manière à ce que les
personnes atteintes puissent rencontrer
un professionnel de santé rapidement
avant que la pathologie soit chronique
Centre national des sports de la défense
à Fontainebleau pour affronter un manque
de sommeil pas de solution miracle mais
un ensemble de mesures préventives et
récupératrices parmi elles les tops ou
techniques d'optimisation du potentiel
petit échauffement à l'issue duquel vous
partirez faire un tour complet des
experts organisent avec nos médecins
chercheurs experts du soleil un stage
sur la gestion de la fatigue pour les
moniteurs de sport donc ces techniques
d'optimisation du potentielle ne
s'appuie sur trois piliers qui sont la
respiration la relaxation et l'imagerie
mentale c'est la gestion émotionnelle en
fait pour être toujours adaptée c'est
comment échecs c'est avoir ce fameux
coup d'avance sur ce qui va venir de
façon à pouvoir faire face au cas où
vous montez tous les quatre sur le tapis
et vous débrouillez pour vous retrouver
sur l'autre face du tapis sans jamais
poser un pied à côté
d'accord tu les recules un peu tôt
pendant 40 heures ces moniteurs vont
être maintenus éveillés au programme
test cognitif et physique le but
constater par eux-mêmes les effets de la
fatigue sur la dégradation de leur
performance
parce qu'il sait pas si c'est une
caresse ou une claque dans le coin qui
va prendre d'accord donc votre main elle
est à plat et elle arrive par le bas et
là vous pouvez avoir accès au dessous de
sa figure à sa joue aux oreilles et puis
après c'est parti
la tâche n'est pas simple il faut savoir
gérer ses émotions et celle de son
cheval je suis médecin du service de
santé des
armes c'est un motif de consultation qui
est assez fréquent et donc j'ai ressenti
le besoin de me former un peu plus et ce
stage était une belle découverte pour
commencer à voir des notions
intéressantes à donner à mes patients on
se rappelle sur les histoires de balance
des perception de la situation c'est pas
forcément l'activité qui est stressante
mais d'un coup comme j'ai beaucoup de
mal à intégrer les informations à
comprendre ce qu'on me demande mon
stress va forcément augmenter ils vont
remplir des questionnaires tout au long
du stage et on va voir la subjectivité
justement de je pense que je suis encore
assez performant alors que les
indicateurs des questionnaires nous
montrent que on a dégradé aux fonctions
de tout le long de la nuit de privation
la nuit se prolonge par un jeu de piste
dans la forêt en petit groupe ils vont
devoir résoudre une dizaine d'énigmes
mais la pluie le froid viennent corser
l'affaire
on a suivi tout ça et on est arrivé là
49 Stella voilà 49 donc on est arrivé là
donc on cherche un arbre jumeau un banc
la clôture cité des c'est déjà passé une
souche ou un trou 9 individus qui
peuvent être résistants à la privation
de sommeil lorsqu'ils sont associés
ensemble vont former un groupe qui va
être parfois très dégradé par la
privation de sommeil parce que le groupe
monsieur hiérarchisent pas ne s'organise
mal au cours de la nuit en effet pour
pouvoir affronter une nuit de travail
faut s'organiser il faut anticiper il
faut se hiérarchiser il faut donner des
ordres qui soient claires il faut se
vérifier se partager les tâches
vous leur interdisons de consommer du
café on fait pour dorer son la première
pour leur montrer que si ils consomment
souvent de la caféine plus de trois
cafés par jour lorsqu'ils vont être en
situation opérationnelle nous pourrons
pas avoir accès au café cela va déjà
dégrader leur performance et les rendre
somnolents on essaie de les convaincre
qu'il faut au quotidien diminuer sa
consommation pour ne pas être dépendant
d'un café et puis qu'ensuite on puisse
voir l'efficacité de contre-mesure comme
la sieste qui sont plus efficaces que la
caféine pour récupérer de leur nuit
blanche pas de café Mint sieste guidée
par un autre expert top
le tout étant d'être
dans la meilleure position possible
afin de récupérer
donc ça nous pique un peu et ça vient
vous chercher mais après voilà on
résiste avec les techniques qu'on arrive
à résister assez facilement où on met
des stratégies en place de façon à
essayer d'être le plus optimum possible
plutôt que d'avoir des écrans j'ai
essayé d'imaginer des coups de points
qu'il fallait que j'esquive voilà
comment j'arrive à rester éveillé mais
si je vois que des chiffres c'est
compliqué à rester éveillé
au petit matin une dernière épreuve les
attend la piscine ils devront mettre en
pratique les techniques qu'ils ont
apprises pour tenir le coup
je vous laisse aller dans l'eau c'est
parti
il n'y a pas de méthode magique il y a
pas de méthode unique pour résister au
manque de sommeil par contre il y a une
boîte à outils de méthodes qui
permettent d'être plus résistant à la
privation de sommeil comme le
l'augmentation de la durée de sommet
mais le qualité avant des siècles la
préparation mentale et surtout on peut
enchaîner des périodes d'activité
opérationnelles sans tomber dans un
cercle de fatigue qui va être une
fatigue qui devient une fatigue
chronique
tout au long de l'année expert top et
médecin chercheur experts du sommeil
collabore étroitement sur la gestion de
la fatigue
expert top pouvoir me confronter à la
réalité du terrain avec des metteur tops
qui reviennent d'opérations extérieures
donc je leur propose des stratégies cela
permet de vérifier avec eux que cela est
bien utilisable dans les forces ça
permet finalement d'avoir un lien entre
l'enseignement la recherche et les
acteurs de terrain sur l'utilisation de
ces techniques qui nous permettent
d'affronter un engagement opérationnel
très fort en France et également en
opération extérieure
en opération extérieure comme sur
barkhane ou des moniteurs top organise
des séances dès que l'activité
opérationnelle le permet
vous pouvez fermer les yeux
c'est vous qui décidez
vous pouvez aussi garder les bras le
long du corps
ou sur le corps
c'est vous qui décidez vous êtes là dans
le but de vous détendre et de vous
relaxer la sensibilisation au début et
un petit peu compliqué parce qu'il faut
déjà gagner leur confiance et faire
tomber beaucoup d'a priori sur les tops
mais après à travers tout un panel de
technique de relaxation où chacun vient
piocher de dans ce qu'il a besoin ils
prennent conscience que ça a un effet
sur l'organisme une fois que vous aurez
effectué vos cinq respirations complètes
relaxantes je vous propose
de relâcher tous vos muscles respiration
complète c'est la respiration sur trois
étages avec le gonflement du ventre le
soulèvement de la cage thoracique les
épaules qui montent à l'inspiration et à
l'expiration en dépla HEC dans l'autre
sens les épaules rentrent la cage
thoracique se dégonfle et le nombril on
imagine que notre nombril veut toucher
notre colonne vertébrale alors ce que je
propose aux personnel qui viennent à
océan un petit exercice le soir tout
simple au moment où ils glissent dans
leur lit d'effectuer 3 ou 5 respiration
complète relaxante et d'associer à cette
respiration une image des détentes qui
va leur permettre de s'endormir plus
vite
les travaux de recherche et l'expertise
de nos médecins du sommeil n'ont cessé
d'améliorer les conditions de vie des
soldats
il continue à s'intéresser aujourd'hui à
des technologies innovantes censé
faciliter l'endormissement et améliorer
le sommeil profond
des dispositifs inventifs qui devraient
peut-être un jour équiper les forces
armées
allez bonne nuit
face à des missions de plus en plus
longues et intense le sommeil ne doit
pas être une variable d'ajustement il
est important que les militaires
veillent à sanctuariser leur moment de
repos